Quando pubblico un episodio di pensieri
in codice, cerco sempre di dedicare il
massimo
impegno per ottenere la migliore qualità
audio possibile. Questo perché ritengo
che un prodotto
che arriva nelle tue cuffie, e quindi
nelle tue orecchie, debba essere molto
curato dal
punto di vista sonoro, ovviamente. Ma
una cosa del genere per un piccolo
podcast come il mio è
relativamente semplice. Hai mai pensato
invece a quanto sia complicato veicolare
il suono in
contesti più complessi, come ad
esempio un concerto o uno spettacolo?
Beh, nell'episodio
della serie Community Edition di oggi,
Alex Ordiner, responsabile tecnico
audiovisivo,
ci illustrerà, con esempi e dovizia di
particolari, proprio le varie fasi
della
gestione dell'audio durante un evento
dal vivo. Dopo la sigla, quindi,
scopriremo come funziona il suono, come
viene gestita la catena audio, quali
sono gli strumenti
tecnici e perché vengono utilizzati in
determinati modi, e, più in generale,
quanto può essere
complessa l'organizzazione di un
qualcosa che, magari, noi diamo per scontato.
Buon ascolto!
Ciao a tutti, ed eccoci qua in questo
piccolo esperimento in cui provo a raccontarvi
il dietro
le quinte di uno spettacolo, di un
evento dal vivo, di una situazione live,
insomma. Più che altro per
capire la parte tecnica di tutta questa
questione, cioè che cosa succede a
grandi linee, che
apparecchiature sono utilizzate, ma
anche che professionalità sono coinvolte
e qual è il ruolo.
Gli aspetti da affrontare sono tanti e,
per esempio, la questione di come funziona
il suono,
ovviamente non sono competente su tutti.
Però, anche decidendo di trattare solo
i principali,
ho valutato che affrontare inizialmente
un solo aspetto potrebbe rendere le
cose più
semplici e comprensibili. Inizierei
quindi dall'audio. Ho pensato di impostarla
così,
e vorrei raccontare quali sono i macroelementi
di una catena audio, inizialmente, e
per poi
andarli a scovare, a rintracciare in
varie situazioni, da quelle più piccole
fino a
eventi medi, per arrivare fino agli
eventi molto grandi. Prima di vedere
proprio praticamente
tutte le apparecchiature coinvolte,
permettetemi di fare una carrellata veloce,
non preoccupatevi,
sulla struttura della catena audio,
quello che avviene in un evento dal
vivo moderno,
e trovare e identificare le sue principali
componenti. Iniziamo quindi questa carrellata
con una semplice immagine in mente. C'è
una persona che sta parlando, un oratore
che sta parlando,
noi siamo gli spettatori di fronte a
lui e sentiamo la sua voce. Allora,
cosa sta succedendo praticamente?
Iniziamo dal nostro oratore. Lui sta
parlando, sta emettendo un suono. E qua
già ci fermiamo
subito. Che cos'è un suono? Non andremo
troppo nel tecnico, chi conosce l'argomento
mi perdoni le semplificazioni, ma il suono
è una variazione di pressione che si
propaga
in un mezzo. Allora, nel nostro caso il
mezzo è l'aria, cioè questo gas che
ci circonda,
l'atmosfera. E un corpo elastico che si
muove in questo mezzo, cioè un corpo
capace di vibrare,
produce un cambiamento di pressione.
Pensate a una corda di una chitarra tesa
fra due punti.
Quando la pizzico, la colpisco, la faccio
vibrare, questa oscilla. Oscillando si
sposta nello spazio
ed è come se in un momento spingesse l'aria
in un verso, poi la corda oscilla dall'altra
parte ed è
come se richiamasse l'aria, poi la rispinge,
la richiama e avanti così, creando dei
momenti di
pressione seguiti subito dopo da dei
momenti di depressione. Ecco, ed è
proprio questa la variazione
di pressione che ci interessa. E questa
cosa la potremmo fare anche semplicemente
spostando la
mano nell'aria, potrebbe venire da pensare.
Cioè spingo la mano lontano da me, poi
la ritiro verso
di me, la rispingo e via avanti. Sto
creando effettivamente delle zone di
pressione e delle
zone di depressione. Però questo
movimento è troppo lento perché il
nostro corpo possa
sentirla. La nostra fisiologia, infatti,
è tratta per sentire delle vibrazioni
che vanno molto
approssimativamente dalle 20 volte fino
alle 20.000 volte.
Proprio la nostra storia evolutiva ha
privilegiato il fatto che fossimo sensibili
a questo range di
frequenze. Non sentiamo né le frequenze
più basse né le frequenze più alte,
quelle che vengono
chiamate suoni subsonici o ultrasuoni.
Abbiamo detto quindi che questa variazione
di pressione
si propaga nel mezzo, nell'atmosfera.
Infatti, come recita un famoso sottotitolo
di un film,
nello spazio nessuno può sentirti urlare
perché manca il mezzo di trasmissione.
Quest'onda di pressione che si propaga,
mano a mano che si allontana dalla sorgente,
cioè nel
nostro caso l'oratore che parla, si affievolisce
col passare dello spazio. Mano a mano
che appunto
si allontana dall'emettitore, il suolo
cara d'intensità fino a diventare inudibile.
Se
quest'onda sonora, prima di essersi affievolita
del tutto, incontra un ascoltatore,
quest'ultimo
tramite i suoi organi di senso,
principalmente le orecchie, non solo ma
diciamo le orecchie,
la percepisce.
La nostra struttura biologica quindi fa
sì che siamo sensibili a questo range
di variazione di
frequenze e mandiamo questi dati al
nostro cervello che li traduce e ci fa
vivere l'esperienza del
suono per come la conosciamo. Quindi
ritorniamo alla nostra immagine iniziale.
Se l'ascoltatore
è troppo lontano, oppure c'è troppa
confusione o l'oratore ha una voce troppo
bassa,
l'ascoltatore non riuscirà a sentire o
comunque a comprendere le parole. Ecco
quindi il
problema che tecnologicamente tenteremo
di risolvere, ovvero quello di farci
sentire.
Storicamente non abbiamo certo incominciato
in tempi recenti ad affrontare questo
problema.
Tecniche ed accorgimenti per farsi sentire
in varie situazioni immagino siano
state inventate
dall'alba dei tempi, è un problema che
ci siamo sempre posti. Abbiamo infatti
sviluppato
tecniche oratorie per aumentare proprio
la voce, abbiamo sviluppato luoghi che
sfruttano
le caratteristiche, la diffusione del
suono a nostro vantaggio.
Abbiamo di fatto inventato i teatri,
gli anfiteatri, gli auditorium, abbiamo
creato il palco dove
chi parla è rialzato rispetto agli ascoltatori.
Insomma, tecniche ce ne sono state tante,
sono
interessantissime, però a noi in
questo podcast interessa la parte tecnologica
della cosa.
Quindi partiamo da quando arriva l'elettronica
in questo mondo a darci una mano.
Che cosa ci siamo inventati quindi? Immaginiamo
di mettere una sorta di orecchio elettronico
vicino al nostro oratore.
Orecchio elettronico capta l'onda sonora,
cioè la variazione del campo di pressione,
e la traduce in un segnale elettrico.
La traduce nella maniera più fedele
possibile, o comunque
con delle caratteristiche che abbiamo
reputate valide per il nostro scopo.
Non è un segnale
elettrico casuale, è un segnale che si
muove in qualche modo copiando il segnale
sonoro,
cioè la mia grandezza fisica. Il suono
infatti viene catturato e tradotto in
un segnale elettrico,
infatti si parla di trasduttore, una
specie di interprete fra queste grandezze.
Questo segnale elettrico, dicevamo, si
muove copiando e mimando il segnale sonoro.
Se c'è
un aumento di pressione nel segnale sonoro
avrò un aumento del valore del segnale
elettrico.
Quando avrò invece una depressione nel
segnale sonoro avrò magari un valore
negativo nel
segnale elettrico. Ecco che appunto
questo segnale varia in maniera analoga
alla variazione
del nostro segnale, della nostra grandezza
fisica del segnale sonoro. Infatti parliamo
proprio di segnale analogico, cioè che
si muove per analogia. A questo punto
ho un segnale
elettrico che, tra virgolette, copia il
mio segnale fisico, il mio suono. Che vantaggi
posso trarne? Beh noi abbiamo imparato
a fare tante cose con un segnale elettrico.
Una di
queste ad esempio è quella di trasportarlo.
Con dei conduttori possiamo trasportarlo
da
un punto ad un altro a una velocità
che per il nostro scopo possiamo tranquillamente
approssimare
all'istantaneità. Posso però fare un'altra
cosa. Posso utilizzare
un orecchio elettronico al contrario. Cioè
mentre prima captavo un'onda sonora e
la traducevo
un segnale elettrico, adesso metto un
altro dispositivo, un altro trasduttore,
che lavora
al contrario. Cioè che riceve in ingresso
un segnale elettrico e mette in
movimento
una membrana, cioè un qualcosa che fisicamente
vibra nell'aria producendo un suono. E
questo
movimento meccanico sarà stato fatto
in analogia al segnale elettrico, che a
sua volta era
in analogia al segnale sonoro. Quindi
in pratica io ho catturato un suono da
una parte, l'ho
buttato nei conduttori e l'ho riemesso
in ambiente in un altro punto dello spazio.
Avrete capito,
immagino che il primo orecchio elettronico,
quello che capta il suono, è quello
che chiamiamo
normalmente microfono, mentre il
secondo orecchio elettronico, quello al
contrario, quello che emette
il suono, è quello che chiamiamo
speaker, cassa, altoparlante. Eccoci
quindi, iniziamo a entrare
nel concreto. Quindi prendo un microfono,
tiro un cavo, lo collego ad un altoparlante
e avrò un suono?
Eh, teoricamente sì, ma in pratica non
funziona così. Non funziona perché il
segnale elettrico che
produce il microfono è veramente piccolo,
è troppo poco potente per poter mettere
meccanicamente in
movimento la membrana dell'altoparlante.
E qua apro una piccola parentesi. Cercherò
di non usare
mai termini come tensione, corrente,
potenza, resistenza, dal punto di vista
tecnico. Utilizziamo
un generico forza o energia, non da un
punto di vista fisico, ma proprio da un
punto di
vista colloquiale. Non ci serve,
secondo me, in questo ambito utilizzare
i termini tecnici precisi,
non stiamo facendo calcoli. Ci serve
invece capirne i concetti generali.
Quindi ritorniamo al nostro
microfono. Genera una corrente piccolissima,
molto poco potente, molto debole, che
non è in
grado di muovere l'altoparlante. E
quindi? Abbiamo già perso? È già finito
tutto? No, perché noi
abbiamo imparato a farci tante cose con
il segnale elettrico. Sappiamo infatti
creare dispositivi
che accettano in ingresso questo segnale
molto molto debole e in uscita ci danno
lo stesso segnale,
ma più potente. E come fanno a funzionare?
Perché in ingresso, oltre al nostro
segnale debole,
ricevono anche una scorta di potenza,
sempre elettrica, che possono utilizzare.
E' la
classica alimentazione di corrente.
Questi dispositivi quindi prendono
questa energia
e la utilizzano per rafforzare il mio
segnale debole, ingrandendolo, rendendolo
più forte,
ma cercando di mantenere il più
possibile intatta la sua informazione.
E
il segnale è sempre quello, è semplicemente
molto più potente. Se metto quindi
questo dispositivo fra
il mio microfono e il mio altoparlante,
prendo il mio segnale molto molto debole,
lo amplifico,
lo rendo molto più forte, lo mando all'altoparlante,
allora sì che lui si muoverà e creerà
un suono
derivato dal mio segnale elettrico.
Questo apparecchio che abbiamo introdotto
è l'amplificatore. Ricevo un
segnale audio debole e sfruttando un'alimentazione
fornisce un'uscita, un segnale audio
amplificato
adatto a muovere meccanicamente.
Questa cosa mi dà subito un altro grosso
vantaggio, oltre che catturare un suono
da una parte in un
punto e riemetterlo in un altro. Mi dà
ad esempio la possibilità di riemetterlo
in un ambiente molto
più forte di quello originale. Ma se
gli oratori sono più di uno, mi serve
quindi un amplificatore,
uno speaker per ogni microfono? Sì,
funzionerebbe, certamente funzionerebbe,
ma è poco conveniente,
sia da un punto di vista logistico che
economico. Però torniamo allo stesso
punto, noi sappiamo
elettrici e un'altra cosa che sappiamo
fare è saperli unire. Posso mettere
quindi più microfoni,
farli convergere tutti in un unico
dispositivo che me li miscela, me li unisce
e mi dà in uscita un
unico segnale che poi verrà amplificato
e andrà agli speaker. Questo oggetto
è il mixer,
perché il miscelatore in italiano suonava
male. Questo mixer poi nella pratica, oltre
a
semplicemente unirmi vari segnali microfonici,
fa tantissime altre cose. Ad esempio mi
livella
i segnali dei microfoni, perché potrei
avere dei microfoni che mi forniscono
un segnale elettrico
molto basso, qualcuno leggermente più
forte, comunque basso, ma leggermente
un po' più forte,
o potrei avere l'audio di un lettore
musicale, di un computer che è più
forte di un segnale
microfonico. Il mixer quindi prende
tutti questi segnali, me li livella con
un primo stadio,
me li porta in una zona di lavoro.
Questo primo stadio viene detto di preamplificazione,
me li pareggia in potenza.
Oltre a questo, questo dispositivo può
anche processare il segnale, può
cambiarne l'equalizzazione,
la dinamica, aggiungere effetti creativi.
Magari di questo faremo qualche piccolo
accenno più avanti.
Quindi abbiamo detto che unisce questi
segnali e crea un'uscita, ma in verità
crea più uscite,
molte uscite differenti a seconda del
nostro scopo. Questo è un aspetto
secondo me interessante
e poco conosciuto, su cui vorrei spendere
due parole più avanti. Ma con questo
secondo me abbiamo
chiuso quelli che sono i macroelementi
principali che troviamo in una catena
audio di un evento
appunto dal vivo. Nel prossimo blocco
andremo a cercare questi elementi all'interno
di situazioni
reali, dalle più piccole alle più
grandi. Eccoci quindi pronti a trovare
i nostri macroelementi
in situazioni reali. Iniziamo da un
esempio molto piccolo. Il venditore a
una festa di paese, a una
sagra, sta parlando usando un piccolo
sistema di amplificazione a una piccola
folla radunata davanti
a lui. Allora iniziamo ad analizzare i
componenti. Il nostro uomo avrà un
microfono ad archetto,
quello che viene collegato all'orecchio
o alla testa, che porta la capsula del
microfono molto
molto vicino alla bocca, attraverso uno
stelo che corre sulla guancia. Mi fermo
subito su questo
esempio per aprire subito una parentesi
e parlare della posizione del microfono
rispetto alla
bocca del venditore. In tutti i casi in
cui andiamo a posizionare un microfono,
la posizione di questo
microfono in relazione alla sorgente
sonora e all'ambiente è uno degli aspetti
più importanti
quando bisogna gestire un'amplificazione,
un evento dal vivo, ma anche altre cose
come ad esempio una
registrazione. Non è assolutamente un
aspetto secondario, anzi. Questo
perché oltre al tipo di
suono, al colore del suono che il
microfono dà, a seconda di dove viene
messo, volevo soffermarmi sul fatto che
il
microfono non sa cosa deve catturare,
cioè non sa cosa interessa a noi, non
sa quello che per noi è
segnale e quello che invece è rumore.
Mi spiego. Nel nostro esempio il venditore
che parla è quello
che definiamo segnale, ma lo definiamo
noi segnale. In quell'ambiente la sua
voce sarà
mischiata col rumore della folla, la
confusione, la musica che è intorno.
Il microfono, questa
differenza fra ciò che è segnale e ciò
che è rumore, non può capirla. Lui è
semplicemente un
trasduttore immerso nell'onda sonora
che lo travolge, che è composta da
tutte queste cose, da quello che
per noi è segnale e da quello che per
noi è rumore. Quindi il nostro scopo,
lo scopo del tecnico, è
quello di posizionare il microfono in
maniera da massimizzare il segnale e
ridurre il rumore già
naturalmente, già solo per come è posizionato
il microfono. E quindi direte voi è
molto semplice, basta
sempre mettere il microfono il più vicino
possibile alla sorgente e in moltissimi
casi è proprio così. Non è
sempre detto però, perché magari pensate
di registrare un pianoforte in una bella
sala con
una bella acustica, per noi parte del
segnale è anche il suono della stanza,
è anche come suona
la stanza. In quel caso il riverbero
farà parte del mio segnale perché gli
darà una connotazione
positiva, mentre molto probabilmente in
una conferenza il riverbero avrà solo
connotazioni
negative. Io cercherò di posizionare
il microfono più vicino possibile all'oratore
per cercarlo di
fare il più possibile dall'ambiente
per garantirne la comprensibilità.
Quindi stabilito che la scelta
di dove posizionare il microfono è
determinante per la riuscita del nostro
intento, ritorniamo al
nostro esempio. Quindi il venditore col
suo microfono ad archetto. Questo
microfono è collegato a una
cassa che vediamo come una scatola nera,
cioè proprio un unico oggetto nero, da
cui sentiamo
uscire il suono amplificato. E quindi
tutti gli elementi che abbiamo visto
prima non ci sono? No,
ci sono proprio tutti, semplicemente
che sono racchiusi in un unico oggetto.
Quindi il segnale
elettrico del nostro microfono viaggia
via cavo o via radio wireless, ma non
entriamo in questa
differenza, entra in questo parallelepipede
e il primo stadio che incontrerà sarà
un
preamplificatore, sicuramente, e potrebbe
anche essere accompagnato da un piccolo
mixer. Pensiamo
ad esempio a una cassa che mi dà la
possibilità di collegare via bluetooth
un telefono. Ecco,
questa è una componente mixer molto
semplice, ma quello è esattamente il
mixer.
L'uscita di questo stadio mixer viene
mandata ad un amplificatore. L'amplificatore
è sempre interno,
non lo vediamo da fuori come elemento
separato. A sua volta questo amplificatore
va all'altoparlante,
sempre internamente. Noi tutti questi
cavi e collegamenti non li vediamo, ma
vediamo un unico
grande oggetto nero. Potremmo addirittura
non vedere nemmeno la presa dell'alimentazione
collegata a questo apparato, ma ciò
non vuol dire che sta lavorando senza
potenza, senza corrente.
C'è e in questo caso è una batteria.
Sarà una cassa a batteria che ogni
tanto dovrà essere
rimessa in carica per funzionare. Passiamo
ora a un altro esempio un po' più
interessante,
è quello di una piccola conferenza. Arriviamo
come spettatori, vediamo un palco, vediamo
un
podio. Sul palco ci sono svariati i
microfoni, non c'è nessuno in questo
momento che sta
parlando, mentre al podio c'è una
persona che sta parlando. Vediamo due
casse ai lati di questo
piccolo palchetto e sentiamo la voce
amplificata. Prima di andare a cercare
tutti gli elementi,
ci immaginiamo la stessa situazione
magari in un teatro, in un piccolo teatrino,
in un auditorium.
Ipotizziamo di avere più difficoltà a
vedere le casse, ad esempio perché in
alcune installazioni
fisse residenti le casse potrebbero
essere state mascherate dietro telefoni
trasparenti,
cioè che sono trasparenti al suono ma
non alla vista, oppure se siamo in strutture
architettoniche
più complesse, più lavorate, potrebbero
essere state integrate nell'architettura
stessa del teatro,
rendendoci di fatto molto difficile
individuarle a vista. Ma torniamo al
nostro palchetto all'aperto.
Sul podio c'è un microfono, potrebbe
essere quello chiamato normalmente gelato,
oppure il collo di
cigno, lo stelo, quei microfoni molto sottili
e snodati, che si allunga dalla base
del podio per
cercare di avvicinarsi il più
possibile alla bocca del nostro oratore.
È quello che abbiamo visto
prima, cercare di posizionare il microfono
più vicino possibile alla voce dell'oratore.
Tutti
questi microfoni sono stati usati per
cercare di avvicinarsi al nostro oratore,
per cercare di
cercare di avvicinarsi al nostro oratore.
Tutti questi microfoni, se seguiamo i
cavi, si concentrano
in quelle che in gergo viene chiamata
ciabatta audio o stagebox, cioè è un
collettore di tutti
questi microfoni che hanno connessioni
meccaniche standard, li racchiude tutto
in un unico grosso
cavo e li porta al mixer. Ipotizziamo
che il mixer sia a fianco al palco.
Questo trasporto è fatto in
analogico, potrebbe essere fatto in
digitale, ma su questa questione vorrei
aprire una parentesi più
avanti, quindi per ora rimaniamo nell'analogico.
In questo caso, rispetto all'esempio di
prima, il
mixer ha il compito di unire più segnali
microfonici, quello del podio, i vari
segnali del
tavolo, oltre magari ad altri contributi,
video da computer, musica da mettere
nei tempi morti e
svariate altre possibili sorgenti audio.
Da questo mixer escono due segnali, tipicamente
uno per il
canale destro e uno per il canale sinistro,
che vanno non più direttamente alle
casse, facciamo
caso, ma ad amplificatori separati,
cioè che sono apparecchiature,
normalmente standard rack, che
è il segnale audio del mixer. A loro
volta forniscono il segnale amplificato
che noi porteremo all'altoparlante,
quindi seguiamo questo cavo che effettivamente
va all'altoparlante. In questo caso
parleremo di
casse passive, cioè che non hanno al
loro interno l'amplificatore, mentre
definiamo le casse attive
quando all'interno dello stesso oggetto
c'è sia il diffusore che l'amplificatore
stesso. Nelle casse
attive ovviamente va portata corrente.
Non c'è una regola per cui è meglio
uno o meglio l'altro, ci sono
diversi vantaggi e svantaggi a seconda
di parecchi fattori. Anche commercialmente,
a livelli medi e
anche molto alti, sono proposte entrambe
le soluzioni, quindi non è che uno è
meglio dell'altro.
Saliamo ancora di livello, passiamo a
quello che potrebbe essere un grosso
evento, un grosso
concerto. Se siete stati a un grosso
concerto, avete visto foto di installazioni,
di eventi di
una certa dimensione, molto probabilmente
avrete notato quelli che si chiamano
line array, cioè
dei moduli che si attaccano ai lati del
palco, con una forma un po' inclinata,
infatti in gergo vengono
anche chiamate banane, proprio perché
scendono piegandosi. Questi sono di
fatto una serie di
altoparlanti modulari, tanti moduli
collegati uno con l'altro e piegate con
strutture appositamente
studiate e appese molto al di sopra
della testa delle persone, proprio per
fare in modo di
distribuire meglio il suono. La progettazione
di questi impianti è un argomento
molto complesso,
parte molte volte proprio da un CAD 3D
dell'ambiente da sonorizzare. L'obiettivo
è quello di bagnare tutta
la platea, l'area da coprire, in maniera
più uniformemente possibile. Bagnare
perché è come
se stessi cercando di appunto bagnare
la mia folla con un tubo dell'acqua.
Non devo fare una cascata
in un punto e lasciare un'altra zona a
secco, cioè devo cercare di distribuire
la quantità di suono
nella maniera più uniforme possibile.
Questi sistemi sono molto importanti,
ma sono anche
i più direttivi, mi permettono di
concentrare il suono dove voglio.
Quindi oltre a evitare che chi
sia sotto il palco venga stordito dal
suono e chi è in fondo non senta quasi
niente, riesce anche a
concentrare il suono solo nella zona di
interesse, cercando di emetterne il
meno possibile in ambiente
per contenere il disturbo che un forte
volume provoca all'esterno della mia
area di interesse,
della mia area di lavoro. Anche in
questo caso possiamo ritrovare i nostri
elementi di partenza,
siamo moltissimi emettitori, moltissimi
casse e altoparlanti e di conseguenza
moltissimi finali,
gli amplificatori, lo stadio finale
della catena prima dello speaker. Anche
in questo caso gli
amplificatori possono essere integrato
nel modulo del line array, ci sono infatti
line array attivi,
oppure oggetti separati e ci sono i
line array passivi. A seconda delle
dimensioni si può
tranquillamente parlare di decine di
finali, magari molti dedicati solo alla
parte più acuta,
altri solo alla parte dei subwoofer.
Tutti questi vengono gestiti separatamente.
Molto bene, ma in questo esempio in
grande siamo partiti però al contrario,
cioè guardando prima
il sistema di amplificazione. Ristalliamo
allora la catena e arriviamo allo stadio
prima, cioè quello
del mixer. Il mixer, e questo è valido
anche per piccoli eventi, è la postazione
in cui il tecnico
opera effettivamente durante l'evento.
Normalmente, se tutto va bene, poi ovviamente
le eccezioni esistono,
tutto il resto dell'impianto, la scelta
dei microfoni, la loro posizione, tutto
il sistema di amplificazione,
la taratura di questo sistema, ecco
tutto questo viene allestito e tarato
prima. Durante l'evento
la stragrande maggioranza del lavoro
viene fatta proprio al mixer ed è lì
che si concentra la quasi
totalità dell'operatività del tecnico.
Questo mixer, anche chiamato banco
audio, gestisce molti
microfoni, ad esempio tutti quelli che
arrivano dal palco se immaginiamo che
ci sia un gruppo che suona.
Poi magari c'è anche una presentazione,
i presentatori parlano, poi arrivano
anche uno o due comici, c'è un
intervento in videoconferenza, ci sono
delle domande dal pubblico della sala,
quindi ci sono dei radio
e microfoni che girano, dei contributi
video. Ecco, adesso non andremo ad analizzare
tutte le varie
casistiche di microfoni e di sorgenti,
ma sappiate che si raggiungono tranquillamente
in un evento dal
vivo svariate decine di canali. Infatti
i mixer vengono scelti, oltre che per
le loro capacità di processo,
per la gestione dei segnali, anche
proprio per il numero di canali che
riescono a trattare. Possiamo
andare da mixer piccoli che trattano pochi
canali, qualche decina di canali e,
perché no, anche più
di 100 canali nel caso delle situazioni
più complesse. Ovviamente per gestire
un numero così
alto di canali ci sono tutta una serie
di tecniche e strategie di raggruppamento
e di utilizzo.
Senza però entrare nel dettaglio sui
molteplici ingressi che un mixer ha,
secondo me è forse più interessante,
anche perché è un po'
meno intuitivo, raccontare invece le uscite
che sono necessarie. Allora, finora
abbiamo pensato solo
all'uscita verso il pubblico, dividendola
magari in due canali, sinistro e destro,
ma in verità adesso
andremo a vedere come di uscite da gestire
ce ne sono molte e sono molto diverse
fra di loro e sono
tutte gestite dal mixer, o meglio dai
mixer, che potremo trovare in una situazione
di evento. Iniziamo
con qualche esempio. I musicisti sul
palco. Ogni musicista, o quasi ogni
gruppo di musicisti, ha un
ascolto dedicato, dove sente un suono
diverso da quello emesso dall'impianto.
È proprio un mix
creato per lui. Se pensate ai monitor
audio, gli altoparlanti, le casse che
sono appoggiate sul bordo
del palco e sono rivolte verso l'interno,
verso i musicisti, oppure sempre più
frequentemente si
vedono gli near monitor, gli auricolari
che tappano l'orecchio, ecco a questi
dispositivi arriva
potenzialmente un segnale molto diverso
da quello che voi sentite come spettatori.
Perché i musicisti
di un ascolto dedicato? Beh, se ci pensate,
ogni musicista avrà la necessità di
sentire il proprio
strumento magari leggermente più alto
rispetto alla media degli altri,
perché in questo modo
può tarare la sua esecuzione in maniera
più precisa. Anche qua, normalmente,
le eccezioni,
come avrete capito, si sprecano in
questo mondo. Ad esempio, un corista
che nel mix finale risulterà
in sottofondo rispetto alla voce del
cantante solista, lui però avrà bisogno
di sentirsi a
di riferimento per prendere intonazione
e tempo. Ecco quindi che sto creando svariati
mix a seconda
dei musicisti o dei gruppi di musicisti.
Chi esegue questi mix? Praticamente chi
li fa? Anche
qua dipende molto dalle dimensioni del
nostro spettacolo. Possiamo andare ad
esempio in
situazioni piccole, in cui c'è un unico
mixer di sala, e addirittura i musicisti
comunicano
col fonico a gesti o con le frasi
durante il soundcheck. Alzami questo,
abbassami quest'altro.
Ma sempre più frequentemente,
soprattutto con l'avvento dei mixer
digitali, è ormai consuetudine
vedere un tecnico di palco con un
tablet. Il tablet è collegato al mixer
principale. Quando
vedete questo tecnico che si aggira fra
i musicisti col tablet in mano, quello
che sta
facendo molto probabilmente è quello
di creare e controllare questi mix,
cioè gli ascolti ai
musicisti. In altre piccole situazioni,
addirittura magari quelli di gruppi o
band che si autogestiscono,
il musicista, tramite lo smartphone, il
telefono, ha un'applicazione che gli
permette di controllare
direttamente la sua spia. Quindi si crea
lui il proprio mix e se lo aggiusta e
se lo tara durante
il concerto e secondo le sue necessità.
In situazioni invece più grandi, dove
la gestione
delle spie è complessa, viene installato
proprio un mixer dedicato, un mixer di
palco. Fisicamente si
trova normalmente a lato del palco, nascosto
dalle quinte, e ha proprio lo scopo di
gestire gli ascolti
e c'è in questo caso un fonico di palco
dedicato a questo. E quindi già a
questo punto abbiamo visto
svariate uscite diverse da quella
principale, tutte che riguardano però
il palco e quello
che succede nel palco. Ma in verità
non abbiamo finito qua. Ad esempio sto
facendo un evento dal
vivo, quindi ho il mio pubblico, la mia
uscita principale, ma sto anche fornendo
l'audio per
lo streaming, o per una videoconferenza,
o per una registrazione. In verità
tutte queste uscite sarebbe
esattamente la stessa cosa. Pensate ad
esempio alla differenza di ascolto che
può avere lo
spettatore presente in sala rispetto a
quello presente in streaming, cioè che
sta guardando
l'evento dallo streaming. Lo spettatore
in sala durante un brano e l'altro, rimaniamo
sull'esempio
del concerto, sente tutta la sala,
tutti gli applausi, la gente che batte
le mani, che fischia,
gli urli, tutto il rumore. Tutto questo
suono non viene ripreso e amplificato
nella sala,
creerebbe solo confusione. Ma chi sta
seguendo l'evento
in streaming non è immerso in quell'ambiente,
non può sentire questo suono. Ecco
quindi che
si potrebbe dedicare una ripresa sonora
del pubblico, o dell'ambiente, della
sala in cui
ci troviamo, e miscelarlo nell'uscita
che viene mandata allo streaming, rendendo
quindi molto
più coinvolgente la visione dello spettacolo.
Possiamo fare velocemente altri tipi di
esempio,
pensiamo a una batteria che suona dal
vivo, magari a un volume sufficiente
per il mio
piccolo pubblico, e quindi non viene
amplificata, o viene molto poco
amplificata in sala. Mentre in
streaming lo strumento dovrebbe essere
molto più presente
rispetto al segnale che mando alle casse,
proprio perché lo spettatore in
streaming
non sente la parte acustica della
batteria. E per finire, anche i livelli
audio variano
molto. Mentre in un evento dal vivo
posso permettermi dinamiche molto forte,
con video emozionali, dove carico molto
il suono, se gestisco lo streaming,
e quindi potenzialmente la gente lo
guarda su un telefono, sulle casse del
computer, non posso
permettermi questi dislivelli di dinamica
così pronunciati.
Ecco quindi che abbiamo fatto alcuni
esempi di possibili uscite argentive,
e ce ne possono essere molte altre. Ma
quindi chi gestisce tutta questa complessità?
Come abbiamo
visto anche un po' negli esempi,
possiamo andare dalla singola persona
che con un singolo dispositivo,
con un singolo mixer, deve gestire
tutto, fino a squadre di svariati tecnici
con specializzazioni di
compiti differenti, apparecchiature
differenti che collaborano e si devono
coordinare fra di loro.
Ed ecco quindi che abbiamo concluso
questa carrellata, questa panoramica di
quello che
potremmo trovare in un evento dal vivo.
Abbiamo individuato i nostri macroelementi.
Ed eccoci arrivati in quest'ultima
parte, dove parleremo un po' più approfonditamente
del mixer,
del banco audio, dove opera effettivamente
il fonico, che cosa fa, perché lo fa.
Però inizierei quest'ultima parte
aprendo una grande
immensa parentesi, ovvero la distinzione
fra il mondo analogico e il mondo digitale.
Ora in questo
podcast non entrerò nel dettaglio
della differenza fra analogica e digitale,
molti di voi probabilmente
la conosceranno già, molti di voi la
conosceranno molto meglio di me. Diciamo
però in maniera
estremamente brutale che quando parliamo
di analogico, di segnale analogico, parliamo
di
segnale elettrici. Quindi siamo più
nel mondo, passatemi questa cosa, fra
virgolette dell'elettronica,
un segnale appunto che mime.
Che si muove in analogia con la mia
grandezza fisica. Mentre nel mondo
digitale è sempre un
segnale elettrico, ma noi lo trattiamo
come una serie di numeri, cioè descriviamo
la grandezza
che ci interessa con dei numeri. Questo
sposta un po' l'attenzione, cioè sposta
il campo di
lavoro da quello che può essere il
mondo elettronico a quello che può
essere un mondo
più informatica. Facciamola così,
lasciamola così molto molto semplice.
Ma quindi perché si fa
questa cosa? Beh, porta innumerevoli vantaggi.
Lasciamo perdere questioni assolute nel
senso
è meglio un mondo oppure è meglio un
altro, non sarà certo questo il luogo
dove risolviamo
questa infinita battaglia. Ma diciamo
che nel nostro caso porta moltissimi vantaggi,
porta
anche qualche svantaggio. Ed è per
questo che nella realtà, nella pratica,
ci troveremo sempre
più spesso ad avere a che fare con
mixer di tipo digitale. Quindi, chiarita
questa cosa, prima di
vedere gli effettivi vantaggi che
abbiamo da un mixer digitale, facciamo
quello che abbiamo fatto
fino ad ora, cioè inseriamo questo
elemento nella nostra catena audio,
cioè dove avviene una conversione
fra analogico digitale e poi viceversa,
da digitale analogico. Perché una
conversione c'è? Un microfono
riprenderà sempre un segnale analogico,
perché è una membrana che si muove,
riceve l'onda sonora.
Un altoparlante, alla fine della catena,
riceverà anche lui sempre un segnale
analogico, perché dovrà
vibrare in maniera analoga al segnale
che vogliamo riprodurre. Quindi nel mezzo
ci sarà una conversione
verso e da il digitale. Anche un microfono
usb, che possiamo considerarlo un
microfono puramente
digitale, come al solito non è altro
che un oggetto che racchiude più
elementi, ovvero un microfono con
la sua parte analogica, probabilmente
un qualche tipo di preamplificatore,
dopo un convertitore
analogico digitale e un'interfaccia usb
per permettermi di interfacciarsi al
computer.
Questi tipi di dispositivo ci sono, ce
ne sono molti, ma nel mondo live è un
po' difficile
trovarli, proprio perché la connessione
usb non ha una connessione adatta a coprire
le grandi
distanze e nel mondo degli spettacoli
al vivo le grandi distanze vanno tenute
in considerazione.
Rimaniamo quindi in una situazione più
classica e diciamo che stiamo usando un
mixer digitale. Un
mixer digitale ha tipicamente alcune
connessioni analogiche al suo interno,
ciò mi permette di
acquisire un certo numero di segnali,
ma non sono tutti i segnali che il
mixer può gestire. Facciamo
un esempio: io ho un mixer che può
gestire 32 canali in ingresso, ma solo
8 o solo 16 di questi
canali me li ritrovo effettivamente
come connessioni analogiche, cioè che
hanno il preamplificatore, i convertitori,
analogico digitale. In questo caso potrei
trasportare le sorgenti che mi arrivano
ad esempio dal palco
tramite delle fruste audio o una stage
box analogica, che sono cioè un raggruppamento
di tanti
segnali audio fatto tramite un unico
cavo al cui interno in verità ci sono
tanti conduttori, che
quindi mi permettono di trasportare agevolmente
diversi canali audio in analogico da un
punto a
un altro. Però come dicevamo potenzialmente
il mixer audio può gestire più di
questi canali e quelli che non riescono
a gestire con le sue connessioni analogiche
interne tipicamente possiamo acquisirli
tramite dei
convertitori analogico digitali e preamplificatori
ovviamente esterni e in questo caso ci
sono proprio
le stage box digitali. Questi dispositivi
hanno al loro interno tutto quello che
occorre per fare la
conversione analogico digitale e mandare
il segnale digitale direttamente al
nostro mixer. Il percorso
quindi dalla stage box al mixer viene
fatto in digitale. Il mixer lo accetta
come uno degli altri canali ed elabora
al segnale
come abbiamo visto prima. Questa cosa
può succedere anche il contrario ovvero
anche per le uscite quindi
io posso avere delle uscite analogiche
direttamente sul mixer oppure il mixer
può fornirmi tramite
delle stage di uscita il segnale audio
che dopo manderò agli amplificatori.
In alcuni casi addirittura
gli amplificatori possono accettare un
segnale digitale e quindi se parlano la
stessa lingua lo
stesso standard posso andare dal mixer
all'amplificatore direttamente in digitale
senza
avere la conversione analogica nel mezzo.
Sarà poi un'altra cosa che si può
fare con il mixer
l'amplificatore a ricreare il segnale
analogico da inviare agli speaker. È
interessante secondo me
capire quali sono le due grosse famiglie
di questo mondo digitale. Sto parlando
di un mondo sicuramente
in evoluzione e ci sono tantissimi
standard ma potrebbe essere
interessante soprattutto in questo
podcast distinguere appunto queste due
famiglie quella un po più digitale
classica e quella invece
nel primo caso cioè quello del segnale
digitale più classico perdonatemi
questo termine non so come
altro definirlo la connessione tra il
mio mixer e la mia stage ad esempio
può avvenire tramite diversi
tipi di cablaggio possono essere cavi
ottici cavi quassiali anche cavi di rete
ma non si parla in
questo caso di rete dati è un segnale
definito con degli standard ci sono
molti standard diversi che
ne determinano il clock la frequenza le
tensioni le correnti in gioco e
possiamo immaginarlo come
una gigantesca trasmissione seriale. Ovviamente
per accoppiare vari dispositivi è assolutamente
richiesto che tali dispositivi utilizzino
lo stesso standard in alcuni casi ci
sono addirittura delle
schede di espansione dedicate ad ogni
standard quindi posso avere nel mio
mixer uno slot di
espansione e compro una scheda che mi
permette di parlare MADI uno standard
digitale oppure
AES50 oppure ADAT insomma ci sono vari
tipi di standard che vengono usati per
vari scopi.
Per quanto riguarda invece il tipo di
trasmissione IP ovvero proprio una trasmissione
dati ultimamente
negli ultimi anni si stanno affacciando
diversi standard ci sono consorti che
si stanno sviluppando
tanti standard diversi per garantire l'interoperabilità
di tutte le apparecchiature
ci sono alcuni che potremmo definire
quasi degli standard di fatto ovvero
sono i più utilizzati e
i più comuni da trovare in tutti i
dispositivi ma la battaglia è ancora
aperta non c'è un unico
vincitore definitivo si stanno ancora
confrontando e probabilmente si svilupperanno
altri tipi di
connessioni in futuro o si creeranno
delle integrazioni fra questi tipi di
connessioni
il vantaggio principale di questo tipo
di trasmissione è quello di poterlo
gestire
esattamente come una rete quindi posso
farlo passare negli switch posso raggrupparli
posso
gestirli crea una specie di matrice
virtuale all'interno della mia rete
dove posso avere
più moduli di ingresso più moduli di
uscita e creo un'infrastruttura molto
molto flessibile
facilmente espandibile è completamente
gestita da un punto di vista proprio haiti
si entra
effettivamente nel mondo nel campo dell'aiti
e dei sistemi questa cosa si porta
anche alcuni
svantaggi ad esempio le problematiche
della rete con la particolare attenzione
perché
nell'audio dobbiamo stare attentissimi
alle latenze poche decine di millisecondi
di ritardo
nel ricreare il segnale possono compromettere
la riuscita di tutta la mia catena
audio quindi ci
sono degli switch che lavorano con
determinati tipi di protocolli bisogna
costruire
le reti in un certo modo ci sono anche
qua delle certificazioni per l'audio
over ip bisogna avere
quindi delle competenze specifiche e
per poter creare gestire questa infrastruttura
di rete se
per una configurazione base cioè dove
colleghiamo un mixer con una stage box
tiriamo un cavo punto
punto tutto tendenzialmente funziona
senza grossi problemi nel momento in
cui creiamo invece molti
nodi interfacciamo molteplici dispositivi
ecco lì non ci si può più improvvisare
e queste sono competenze
che iniziano ad allontanarsi dal mondo
dell'audio puro e si avvicinano al
mondo dei sistemi dell'ait
a tutta questa complessità si aggiunge
anche poi il mondo del video che anch'esso
sta affrontando
un'evoluzione che lo porta sempre di
più verso il mondo delle rete dati infatti
tutto questo mondo lo
si trova spesso riassunto con la voce
ip over ip cioè audio e video su trasmissioni
ip ok detto
tutto questo che vantaggi ci dà affrontare
tutta questa complessità del mondo
digitale
come prima cosa però assolutamente non
scontata è che in una trasmissione
digitale possiamo garantire
un trasporto del segnale molto pulito
privo di interferenze o meglio non è
privo di interferenze
ma fintanto che il segnale digitale è
perfettamente intellegibile non avrò
differenza fra il mio punto
di appartenza e il mio punto di arrivo
un segnale analogico invece si deteriora
nel percorso va
trattato con molta cura un altro grosso
vantaggio è quello della dimensione e
del peso che sembra
forse sciocco ma non lo è assolutamente
cioè nel mondo analogico ha bisogno di
un certo spazio fisico dove far stare
la circuiteria ogni
canale dispone di una certa circuiteria
quindi all'aumentare del numero di canali
devo
necessariamente aumentare lo spazio a
disposizione un mixer a 8 canali sarà
fisicamente più piccolo
e peserà molto meno di un mixer a 32
48 canali sarà necessariamente più
grande con un maggior
peso e un maggior costo anche di trasporto
e di gestione e non si parla solo del
numero di canali
un mixer digitale mi permette tutta una
serie di elaborazioni del segnale che
per farle in analogico
avrei bisogno di quello che si dice un
outboard cioè un processore esterno
analogico specifico
per quel tipo di processo è un oggetto
che ha un suo peso un suo ingombro un
certo costo e occupa
un certo spazio nella mia regia ad
esempio se voglio avere un compressore
sulla voce magari
più avanti accenniamo ad alcuni di
questi processi nel mondo analogico avrò
bisogno effettivamente di
un compressore che può trattarmi per
un'altra cosa che è un'altra cosa che
è un'altra cosa che è
pochi canali alcuni processi sono già
integrati nei mixer analogici ma sono
proprio quelli basilari
in tanti altri casi si usavano e si usano
tuttora per chi sceglie la strada
analogico outboard esterni
quindi rack interi a fianco al mixer e
chiaramente se lo devo fare per pochi
canali uno o due canali
è un discorso ma se voglio immaginare
di avere un compressore su ognuno dei
miei che ne so 32 canali
devo avere 32 compressori la faccenda
inizia a diventare un po complicata da
gestire nel mondo
invece ho i compressori in molti casi
addirittura posso avere delle simulazioni
fatte più o meno bene
dei processori analogici perché magari
mi piacciono particolarmente quel tipo
di processo analogico e
col passare degli anni ultimamente è
sempre più facile riuscire ad avere un'emulazione
digitale
dell'effetto che avevo in analogico
molto bene e quindi che cosa fa un
mixer questo oggetto su cui
alla fine abbiamo visto che si concentra
quasi tutta l'operatività del nostro
tecnico è ovviamente
facile raccontare tutto e forse anche
poco interessante ma facciamo delle
macro categorie
di processo alcuni riguardano la dinamica
ovvero la differenza fra i suoni più
forti e i suoni più
bassi e quindi possiamo ridurre questa
dinamica possiamo ampiare questa dinamica
e tutto con lo
scopo di focalizzare l'attenzione sulla
parte di suono che ci interessa quindi
magari rafforzando
le parti basse della voce oppure al
contrario riducendo il brusio che
invece non vogliamo
amplificare solo per fare un esempio ci
sono poi interventi che riguardano l'equalizzazione
quindi
senza entrare nello specifico diciamo i
suoni più scuri e suoni più acuti
più brillanti e allora
anche in questo caso andiamo a rafforzarne
alcuni andiamo a eliminarne altri a
seconda di quello che
ci interessa ci sono poi degli interventi
specifici molto tecnici pensiamo ad
esempio
all'effetto larsen cioè il fischio che
quasi sicuramente avete sentito in un
evento dal vivo
cioè quel fastidioso effetto che si
verifica quando il microfono capta se
vogliamo in maniera
troppo forte il suono che esso stesso
amplifica provo a spiegarlo in due
parole molto semplicemente
io parlo un microfono la mia voce viene
amplificata e la voce amplificata però
rientra anche nel
microfono che a sua volta verrà amplificata
che a sua volta rientrerà nel microfono
e ci sarà un
livello in cui questo loop si autoalimenta
generando proprio il fischio perché
per ragioni tecniche
l'unico modo in cui l'unico modo in cui
il fischio può essere amplificato è
con l'utilizzo di un
dispositivo che si chiama larsen che
viene prima su alcune frequenze specifiche
ecco quindi che con
un intervento particolare sull'equalizzazione
vado a cercare di togliere energia in
queste
frequenze problematiche per cercare di
ridurre l'effetto larsen di ridurre la
probabilità che
questo fischio si inneschi come ad
esempio posso equalizzare anche le uscite
ovvero la mia diffusione
in sala perché l'ambiente ogni sala
reagisce in maniera diversa e quindi avrò
bisogno di aumentare
meglio il mio suono abbiamo poi tutta
una serie di effetti se vogliamo più
creativi come i
riverberi i delay i chorus ovvero ovvero
tutta una serie di cose che rendono
più piacevole il
mio suono o addirittura proprio che le
uso in maniera creativa per creare per
generare un
certo tipo di effetto questo avviene
molto di più ovviamente nel musicale
rispetto che nella
conferenza però sono tutti strumenti
che il fonico a disposizione deve saper
usare e calibrare all'esigenza
e quindi per finire operativamente il
nostro tecnico che cosa fa durante l'evento
beh lui
avrà fatto quasi sicuramente anche le
prove prima o se non lo ha fatto avrà
una scaletta dovrà
interagire con tutte le persone che
sono andate sul palco e quindi dovrà
seguire di fatto quello
che succede nell'evento accendere spegnere
i microfoni adattarli a seconda delle
esigenze
modellare il suono secondo le varie esigenze
e seguire in pratica quello che succede
sul palco
passatemi il paragone come se fosse il
cuoco e il cameriere che vi serve il piatto
in tavola cioè
che prende gli ingredienti grezzi ovvero
il prodotto dell'artista sul palco li
unisce li
plasma li confeziona li miscela per voi
e ve li serve al vostro tavolo e oltre
a tutta la dimensione
tecnica che abbiamo visto finora non
sottovalutiamo tutta una dimensione è
un aspetto umano soprattutto
con quei tecnici che hanno a che fare
sempre con persone diverse problematiche
diverse ed esigenze
diverse sapersi interfacciare con le
persone in situazioni che possono
essere molto stressanti
come quelle degli eventi dal vivo
perché non lasciano molto tempo per
prendere delle decisioni
o per risolvere dei problemi ecco la
componente umana nell'affrontare nel
cercare di risolvere
queste problematiche tutte insieme fa
molto secondo me e non è da sottovalutare
e proprio per finire
in coda non vogliamo spendere le ultime
parole per parlare delle evoluzioni
future citando addirittura
artificiale ecco con queste ultime due
parole probabilmente ho già perso la
quasi totalità di
voi perché effettivamente è un
problema sentire a parlare molto spesso
a sproposito di questo
argomento però volevo lanciarmi in
quella che può essere una proiezione
futura data dalla mia
esperienza e queste sono considerazioni
assolutamente personali in questo caso
non c'è assolutamente
niente di tecnico su quello che potremo
aspettarci nei prossimi anni sicuramente
l'evoluzione del
digitale con la sua capacità di risolvere
le problematiche e di risolvere le
problematiche
di calcolo la farà da padrona e vedremo
arrivare o affinare nuovi processi in
questa catena non credo
si arriverà entro breve a una sostituzione
del tecnico alla sua professionalità
credo piuttosto
che compariranno sempre di più a costi
sempre più accessibili strumenti a
supporto del suo
lavoro magari molto automatici ma che
comunque si vanno integrare nel suo flusso
di lavoro mi
vengono in mente ad esempio gli ultimi
algoritmi di pulizia del suono che si
possono utilizzare in
una situazione in cui si inizia a
vedere qualcosa anche nelle situazioni
live in cui ovviamente il
tempo di elaborazione deve essere estremamente
ridotto e se non virtualmente assente
come pure
vedo sempre più probabile l'ingresso
di automatismi di automixing cioè di
una gestione semi automatica
dei livelli magari in una situazione
molto più controllata come può essere
quella di una
conferenza oppure come ultimo esempio
la taratura di un impianto potrebbe trarre
molto vantaggio
poterla fare anche a chi non ha competenze
specifiche
sulla terratura degli impianti ma riesce
comunque con un sistema automatico a ottenere
un buon
risultato magari lui si concentra o
può concentrarsi su altri aspetti del
lavoro e con questo direi che
ho finito spero di avervi almeno in
parte incuriosito e perché no la prossima
volta che
assisterete che so a un concerto buttate
un occhio al dietro le quinte a tutta
la parte tecnica che
si cela nascosta normalmente agli occhi
del pubblico grazie a tutti voi che
siete sopravvissuti
grazie mille a valerio che mi ha dato
la possibilità di raccontarvi queste
piccole
cose e continuate a seguire il podcast
pensieri in codice grazie a tutti di
nuovo e ciao
grazie mille a te alex per averci fatto
capire che dietro la gestione del suono
di un evento
c'è un intero mondo di tecnologia di
software e di persone al lavoro e
complimenti anche per
la chiarezza e l'impegno so che non è
banale produrre 40 minuti di video ma
è un'ottima
e un'ottima scelta e un'ottima scelta
per i nostri amici e per tutti i nostri
amici e per tutti i
amici e quindi il mio modo di pensare
si riflette su ogni aspetto della mia
vita compreso questo
progetto quando dunque alex si è proposto
per un episodio della serie community
edition
nonostante i suoi dubbi sul fatto che l'argomento
non fosse prettamente legato al
software io ho
subito pensato che sarebbe stato invece
un contenuto interessantissimo da condividere
e penso di non essermi sbagliato tu che
ne dici secondo me ho
oggi abbiamo imparato tutti qualcosa di
nuovo me compreso ed è questo il senso
di questa serie
alex che ripeto nella vita è responsabile
tecnico audiovisivo mi ha detto anche
che ha intenzione di
aprire un proprio progetto divulgativo
io dico che ci sono tutte le carte in
regola quindi mi
sento di incoraggiarlo assolutamente
non so quando ciò diverrà realtà ma
se vuoi saperne di più su
audio e argomenti tecnici del genere se
vuoi sapere di più su audio e argomenti
tecnici del
genere se vuoi saperne di più su audio
e argomenti tecnici del genere se vuoi
saperne di più su audio
saperne di più su audio e argomenti tecnici
del genere ti consiglio di unirti al
gruppo telegram di pensieri in codice
dove sono sicuro alex ci terrà aggiornati
sulle novità del suo progetto nel frattempo
veniamo al consueto invito come hai
sentito questa nuova rubrica si chiama
pensieri in codice community edition
perché è uno spazio pensato apposta
per te che fai parte della community
del podcast se hai un'idea che ti affascina
un'esperienza interessante da raccontare
o se hai un'idea che ti affascina un'esperienza
interessante da raccontare o se hai un'idea
che ti affascina un'esperienza
interessante da raccontare o se
semplicemente un argomento legato al
mondo dell'informatica che ti appassiona
e che ritieni adatto per questi microfoni
perché non lo condividi è un modo
fantastico per metterti alla prova e
supportare attivamente il progetto impiegando
il tuo talento e restituire un po del
valore che spero tu riceva ascoltando
pensieri in codice te lo assicuro non
è complicato e non serve essere un
esperto o avere un'attrezzatura
professionale come dico sempre
è quasi come registrare un vocale e in
ogni caso ci sarò io a guidarti passo
passo quindi se hai una proposta puoi
contattarmi su telegram o scrivermi all'indirizzo
email valerio chiocciolapensierincodice.it
mi raccomando con due i e ne parliamo
insieme trovi tutti i link sul sito
pensierincodice.it io non vedo l'ora di
sentire le tue idee prima di salutarci
inoltre ti rinnovo il mio
invito a riflettere sulla filosofia
value for value su cui si fonda questo
progetto ancora una volta pensieri in
codice è un podcast totalmente indipendente
libero da pubblicità e da tracciamenti
che porto avanti esclusivamente nel mio
tempo libero e con le mie risorse
personali e con un po di aiuto da parte
della community questo vuol dire che
per sopravvivere e continuare a crescere
ha bisogno anche del tuo supporto
l'idea è semplice se ascolti tanti
episodi se magari hai imparato qualcosa
di nuovo o hai trovato uno spunto
interessante ti chiedo di fermarti un
secondo e riflettere quanto vale per te
questo progetto se la risposta è che
un valore ce l'ha allora ti chiedo di
valutare senza nessun obbligo se restituirne
una piccola parte puoi farlo nei tre
modi che la filosofia value for value
ti fa
ci insegna time talent o treasure time
puoi dedicare un po del tuo tempo per
far crescere pensieri in codice il passaparola
è fondamentale quindi condividi questo
o un altro episodio con un amico un
collega o sui tuoi social portare nuovi
ascoltatori è il primo modo per sostenere
tutta la baracca talent se hai competenze
che pensi possano essere utili mettile
a disposizione
come dico spesso mi farebbe comodo una
mano per aprire e gestire i canali
social ma magari tu sai scrivere sai
fare ricerche o vuoi proporti per un
episodio della community edition beh
scrivimi e parliamone infine treasure
puoi scegliere di dare un supporto
economico anche piccolo è quello che fanno
donatori come edoardo e carlo che ringrazio
sempre per il loro sostegno mensile
se vuoi unirti a loro trovi tutti i modi
per farlo come ad esempio satisfei o
revolute nella sezione sostieni del sito
pensieriincodice.it sempre con due i mi
raccomando qualsiasi modo sceglierai il
tuo contributo sarà prezioso e apprezzato
a questo punto direi che ci siamo detti
proprio tutto e ci possiamo salutare
dandoci appuntamento al prossimo episodio
e ricordando sempre che un informatico
risulta
risolve problemi a volte anche usando
il computer.